I need to talk to you about this bogus
scam explanation that Donald Trump is
bragging about about how he is going to
save or prevent a thousand jobs from the
carrier corporation from moving to
Mexico so the background let's set the
stage Trump has been talking about
bringing back manufacturing jobs keeping
manufacturing jobs etc last week we
exposed the bogus story about Trump
claiming he negotiated to get Ford to
change their minds and keep a factory in
the US that they were about to close the
entire story was BS on many levels I
won't rehash it now but check that in
the archives for more info so during the
campaign Trump talked about carrier this
big air conditioner company moving 2,000
jobs from Indiana to Mexico and he
talked about how that's a disaster
it talked about how Obama can't stop
them he talked about how he would impose
huge penalties and tariffs for companies
that are moving jobs away today Trump
and pence are appearing in Indiana to
announce that they will have made this
heroic deal with carrier to keep a
thousand jobs in the state of Indiana
Donald Trump tweeted about this he said
big day on Thursday for Indiana and the
great workers of that wonderful state we
will keep our companies and jobs in the
u.s. thanks carrier carrier also tweeted
about this saying we are pleased to have
reached a deal with president elect
Trump and VP elect pence to keep close
to a thousand jobs in Indiana more
details soon well this is a major
victory right how did Trump do this so
heroic well in exchange for keeping the
factory running in Indianapolis Trump
and pence are expected to reiterate
their campaign pledges to be friendlier
to business by scaling back regulations
overhauling the corporate tax code to
reduce taxes paid by corporations
according to a spokeswoman for Donald
Trump the state of Indiana also is
agreeing as part of this deal to give
economic incentives to carrier as part
of the deal to stay and he provision
here quote from the new year
times in addition mr. Trump is expected
to tone down his rhetoric threatening
35% tariffs on companies like carrier
that shift production south of the
border let me explain to you the scam
that is involved here number one we were
talking about 2,000 jobs this deal will
keep 1,000 jobs in the US and Trump is
going to tone down talk of 35% tariffs
for moving jobs to Mexico meaning that
1,000 of the 2,000 will stay in Indiana
but Trump is going to allow that other
thousand to go to Mexico without so much
talk about those 35% tariffs meaning the
thousand jobs that carrier will still
move will be far less expensive for them
and they are keeping a thousand jobs
because Trump is giving them money if
you give people money you can get them
to do anything right that that's not
really a sustainable solution yet
they're staying because you gave the
money and are telling them that you'll
tax them less for the jobs that they
move to Mexico it doesn't change
competitiveness it doesn't change the
business climate it's actually not free
market the free market here would have
dictated that the economic situation was
better in Mexico for these jobs than in
the United States Trump went in and
messed with the free market by giving
incentives to this company to stay this
is the opposite of free market yeah I
mean I may be a little bit more poised
to give him some credit than you are on
this because he's fulfilling a campaign
promises so it seems at least on optics
but we don't know what they offered him
the company to begin with it could have
been seven million dollars I guess in
tax credits they could have threatened
to take away defense contract from their
parent company sure there's a lot there
but I I don't know that I agree with you
because yes he said one of the things he
would do is keep jobs he said that
during his campaign that's true but he
also said he was going to give companies
really harsh penalties for moving jobs
elsewhere and part of the deal
reportedly is he's no longer going to be
so tough about imposing those penalties
for moving jobs elsewhere so that's sort
of that's a broken promise right I mean
I'm saying this is a victory more so on
optics because he's going to go around
now and give a whole parade oh yeah
round the country about how he saved all
these jobs even though in the grain
scheme of things a thousand jobs yes
it's important but not in a country of
300 million people this is very
important to the thousand employees and
their families and the local businesses
where they will spend money there's no
doubt but Pat is alluding to something
that's really important let's not lose
the context the economy has created an
average of a hundred and eighty-one
thousand jobs per month in 2016
giving money making an individual deal
to give money to carrier to save a
thousand jobs is not sustainable
economic policy carrier made a financial
decision they would have saved sixty
five million dollars by moving the two
thousand jobs to Mexico they're now
going to keep a thousand because they're
getting some piece of that sixty five
million in incentives they're also going
to get deregulation from Trump they'll
avoid the PR problem of moving the jobs
which would have had another financial
impact this is a business decision you
can't do this for every company that's
looking at moving jobs out of the US
it's not sustainable mathematically it's
optics and PR because carrier is a
company Trump has been talking about but
this is not economic policy and it is
certainly not the free market but I
think you would agree Pat that the
trumpets will see this and they will say
he made America great again because
they're taking office yeah as if he
fulfilled the campaign promise before he
even got into office yep no I think
you're right they will see it that way
and Trump is doing a press conference
he's doing the entire thing it is all a
sham this is not economic policy and it
is absolutely a plain to see that you
can't replicate this to keep companies
from moving overseas not at the at a
large level total PR and optics send me
your thoughts if you disagree I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
program is made possible by blue apron
I've talked about blue apron before you
get freshly delivered and perfectly
portioned ingredients so you can number
one cook at home
and number two end up without leftovers
I hate when I buy an entire package of
celery for one recipe and then now I'm
munching on celery the entire week or I
end up throwing celery out and the great
thing about blue apron is that not only
can it be delivered to 19
9% of the continental US 99.5% of food
deserts an issue I've talked about
before for less than 10 bucks per meal
you're getting seasonal recipes that
aren't ever repeated within the year and
you get the exact amount of ingredients
that you need one of the recipes this
week I actually cooked last night it's
the green coconut curry with sweet
potato and jasmine rice it was fantastic
and you can check out this week's entire
menu and get your first three meals for
free with free shipping might I add by
going to blue apron dot-com slash Pakman
that's PA que ma n blue apron dot-com
slash Pakman it's a better way to cook
with blue apron